>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOINING US WITH
REACTION TO THE LEFT WING
RESPONSE TO THE ON-GOING SUPREME
I CALL HIM THE GREAT ONE.
I?
>> I WILL SAY IT.
I AM PREGNANT!
>> Sean: [LAUGHING].
NO, HE WAS JUST APPOINTED TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> I JUST SELF-IDENTIFIED.
YOU ARE MY GUEST.
I WILL INTERVIEW YOU FOR AN
HOUR.
>> Sean: THAT ROLE REVERSAL
THING IS WEIRD FOR ME.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
MARK, YOU ARE PROBABLY BEST
KNOWN FOR YOUR RUN AWAY BEST
LONG BEFORE ANYBODY ELSE.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS WHAT THE
LEFT CAN ACCOMPLISH IN AN
ELECTION.
WHAT THEY CAN'T ACCOMPLISH.
THEY WANT TO IGNORE SEPARATIONS
OF POWERS CO-EQUAL BRANCHES AND
THEY WANT THINGS LEGISLATED FROM
THE BENCH.
THIS PRESIDENT WANTS TO CHOOSE
AN ORIGINALIST.
GO THROUGH THEIR REACTION TO
THIS OPENING NOW AND WHAT IT
MEANS FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I WANT
AMERICANS TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PROGRESSIVE IDEALOGY ON THE LEFT
IS INCOMPATIBLE WITH THE
CONSTITUTION.
THEY TURNED THE SUPREME COURT
INTO A ALL-POWERFUL, CENTRALIZED
POLITICAL OPERATION WHERE THEY
WANT TO CONTROL A MAJORITY OF
THE SEATS.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT UPHOLDING
THE CONSTITUTION OR TALK THIS
THIS ARTICLE OR THIS SECTION OR
CLAUSE OF THE CONSTITUTION.
WHEN YOU HEAR THEM YACK AWAY ON
THE OTHER NETWORKS THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT ABORTION ON
DEMAND.
SAME SEX MARRIAGE AND OBAMACARE
AND OPEN BORDERS.
THEY GIVE YOU THE SAME LEFT WING
AGENDA AS IF THEY ARE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT OR THE SENATE WHAT
THEY WANT IN A NOMINEE.
WE DON'T WANT A CONSERVATIVE.
WE DON'T WANT A LIBERAL.
WE WANT A CONSTITUTIONALIST.
LOOKS AT THE CONSTITUTION AND
THE WORDS.
TAKES THEM THIS CONTEXT.
TRIES TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
ORIGINAL INTENT WAS AND APPLIES
IT.
THE PARTIES BEFORE THE SUPREME
COURT HAVE A RIGHT TO EXPECT
THAT'S WHAT THE JUSTICES WILL
DO.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TELLING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
IF YOU DON'T NOMINATE RUTH BADER
GINSBERG IN ONE FORM OR ANOTHER,
WE WILL OPPOSE WHOMEVER YOU
NOMINATE.
THE REPUBLICANS WILL HAVE TO
STEAM ROLL THE DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S OKAY.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T MAKE SENSE.
NOW THEY OPPOSE FILIBUSTERS.
NOW THEY OPPOSE IT IN MID-TERM
ELECTIONS.
FORGET ABOUT SCHUMER AND THE
DEMOCRATS.
LET US UPHOLD OUR CONSTITUTION.
THE PRESIDENT UNDERSTANDS THAT.
HE RAN FOR OFFICE AND HAD
A LIST.
HILLARY CLINTON DIDN'T HAVE
FRANKLY.
BUT THIS PRESIDENT HAD A LIST.
HE HAS TREMENDOUS CANDIDATES ON
THIS LIST.
HE SAID I WILL CHOOSE FROM THIS
PRESIDENT IS STICKING TO THE
LIST.
THIS IS VERY, VERY IMPORTANT.
THE SUPREME COURT IS NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE MORE POWERFUL
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE INDEPENDENT.
IT'S GOTTEN WAY OUT OF WHACK.
THE ATTITUDES OF THE
PROGRESSIVES WHO USED TO ATTACK
THE CONSTITUTION AS WRITTEN BY
A BUNCH OF WHITE MEN WHO OWNED
SLAVE.
NOW THEY PRETEND TO SUPPORT IT.
THE POSITION OF THE LEFT:
THEY WANT TO ENSHRINE THEIR
IDEALOGY INTO THE CONSTITUTION.
WHEN THEY SAY SUPPORT PRECEDENT,
WAS PRESIDENT.
SEGREGATION WAS PRECEDENT.
NO, WHAT THEY MEAN IS THE MOST
RADICAL DECISION OF THE SUPREME
COURT THAT'S WHAT I BELIEVE IN.
NOT THE CONSTITUTION.
BUT THE LEFTIST DIRECTION THAT
THE COURTS HAVE TAKEN THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> Sean: YOU WROTE "MEN IN
BLACK."
>> IN 2005, I THINK.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE REASONS WE
GAME FRIENDS AND I THINK WE WENT
INTO THIS A LITTLE BIT.
MARK, WE BECAME FRIENDS BECAUSE
OF ISSUES.
I WILL TELL A LITTLE BIT OF THE
STORY.
FOR ME ON RADIO.
TWIST YOUR ARM TO DO A WEEKEND
SHOW.
TWIST TO IT DO 6 TO 9.
TO BE HONEST, IT'S BEEN YEARS I
HAVE BEEN TWISTING YOUR ARM TO
COME ON THIS TV SHOW.
NOW YOU ARE HERE.
NOW YOU FLIPPED IT AND I HAVE TO
TOGETHER.
>> I WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT.
I WANT YOUR VIEWERS TO KNOW
SOMETHING.
WE JUST DID THIS INTERVIEW.
I WANT THE VIEWERS TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT YOU KNOW THAT WHEN YOU ARE
ON TV.
YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL BRACKED.
HOLD ON YOU GIVE ME 20 BUCKS, I
HAVE TO FINISH.
I WANT THE PEOPLE TO KNOW THE
REAL SEAN HANNITY.
THAT WILL HAPPEN.
>> Sean: I DID SOMETHING A LOT
OF LIBERALS DO.
HE TRIED TO GET ME TO TALK IT ME
AND I TALKED ABOUT ISSUES.
STOP IT, TALK ABOUT YOU.
YOUR LOVE OF THIS CONSTITUTION
HAS BEEN YOUR LIFE STUDY.
IMPORTANT.
IF WE DON'T GET THIS RIGHT, WE
WILL LOSE THIS COUNTRY.
OF ALL OF OUR LAWS.
YOU ARE HAVE HEAVYWEIGHT ON ALL
OF THIS.
>> LET ME SAY ONE THING.
THE PROGRESSIVES DON'T OWN THE
CEMENT.
THEY -- SUPREME COURT.
STOP!
>> Sean: YOU LIKE MIKE LEE?
I THINK HE WOULD BE OUTSTANDING.
>> Sean: HE IS BRILLIANT.
A GREAT CHOICE.
MARK, LIFE, LIBERTY AND LEVIN
EVERY SUNDAY NIGHT ON CABLE AT